je pense que j'étais en tout cas dans le
monde cinématographique la première à
être comme ça dépouillée de tout
artifice naturel
bonne ou mauvaise selon les cas mais en
tout cas absolument il y a une rupture
avec votre milieu familial et social
non
oui enfin oui non parce que il est
certain que va s'allonger était élevé
était très différente de ce que de la
vie que j'ai vécu par la suite c'est
vrai que élevé dans un milieu
extrêmement bourgeois et ça se retrouve
un petit peu je l'ai pas complètement
oublié oui moi ce qui m'intéresse
beaucoup c'est votre attitude
par rapport aux formidable mouvement
d'émancipation de la femme que vous
n'avez pas évidemment suscité mais dont
vous avez été un peu une pionnière si
vous voulez par votre façon d'être votre
façon de vivre un garçon faire en faire
qu'à votre tête suivre votre bon plaisir
tout à fait en dehors de toutes les
conventions bourgeoises sociales et de
toutes les traditions et j'aurais voulu
connaître votre sentiment sur le
mouvement de libération de la femme
telle qu'il s'articule maintenant en
Amérique et puis un petit peu partout
dans les pays d'Europe j'ai l'impression
il me semble avoir lu quelque part que
vous étiez très con enfin je suis pas
vraiment compte je trouve que c'est très
bien que les femmes se libèrent
mais pourquoi faire un mouvement pour ça
on peut se libérer sans devenir
suffragète et porte-drapeau d'un
mouvement
je trouve qu'une femme doit rester une
femme avant tout bon qu'elle se libère
c'est très bien mais avant tout elle
doit se dire que la femme c'est quand
même la chose la plus belle du monde si
elle reste vraiment une vraie femme bon
le fait de se libérer c'est de plus
supporter le joug de l'homme qui veut
pas vous donner tant d'argent c'est de
pouvoir vivre et gagner sa vie sans
dépendre de personne c'est très très
bien d'un autre côté je crois que les
femmes en voulant trop se libérer vont
devenir de plus en plus malheureuse dans
quel sens pourquoi parce qu'une femme
n'est pas faite pour amener la vie d'un
homme et je crois que c'est là où
vraiment la société dans laquelle nous
vivons actuellement et de complètement
déséquilibré parce que les femmes
veulent commencer à avoir des métiers et
des vidoms puis les hommes restent à la
maison ils s'occupent des enfants mais
c'est rare comment c'est rare pas du
tout moi je connais des exemples parmi
des amis à moi quelquefois les hommes
n'ont pas de travail restent à la maison
s'occupe de ce qu'il y a à faire et les
femmes travaillent bon ça donne un
déséquilibre pas forcément parce qu'une
femme n'est pas faite pour ça à mon avis
bon c'est très bien que les femmes se
libèrent moi je suis la première à
trouver qu'il faut qu'on les femmes
puissent vivre librement mais d'un autre
côté on ne peut pas vivre comme un homme
n'est pas c'est ce que vous faites vous
non
mais regardez vous gagnez largement
votre vie ce qui permet de vivre comme
vous l'entendez je gagne ma vie je ne
dois rien à personne mais je suis
vraiment l'image même d'une femme et
dans ma vie je suis une femme je ne suis
pas un homme je ne suis pas une
suffragète et je suis faible
vulnérable oui c'est un être qui
assez faiblesses au combien est assez
vulnérable et physiquement n'a pas la
force non plus d'un homme une femme
c'est un être doux je crois que c'est la
douceur doit vraiment faire partie
intégrante de la femme
mais vous qui êtes tellement contre
l'agressivité quand on toutes ces
notions toute la guerre toute l'horreur
toute la violence tout le sang vous qui
aimez les bêtes comment est-ce que vous
pouvez
réserver ses vertus aux seules femmes
vous devriez souhaiter que les hommes
les partages que les hommes soient doux
gentils là pour le moment on parle des
femmes bon alors sérieux les problèmes
vous dites que la tendresse et la
gentillesse sont des vertus typiquement
et uniquement féminine et vous vous
distinguez de cette manière la femme de
l'homme le principe oui je dis en
principe bon un homme peut-être tendre
et doux au départ c'est parce qu'on lui
demande c'est très très bien tant mieux
s'il est tendre et doux par dessus le
marché mais au départ c'est la femme qui
doit être tendrée douce c'est la femme
qui doit donner l'ambiance de
merveilleux chaleurs d'une maison de la
femme qui doit
agrémenter la maison pour que l'homme
s'y sente bien et je trouve dommage que
les femmes maintenant tout en se
libérant ce que je trouve très très bien
perd un peu cette notion de
de beauté de
en travaillant en allant au dehors en
participant aux affaires à la vie
politique à la vie sociale elle
risquerait de perdre ses vertus
féminines de douceur et de gentillesse
les perdre forcément étant donné que une
femme qui travaille revient épuiser le
soir de son travail elle ne peut pas
donner à ce moment-là à l'homme avec qui
elle vit ou à ses enfants ou aux
personnes avec qui elle partage son
appartement ou sa vie les avantages
qu'une femme qui n'aurait que ça à faire
pour elle donner mais vous Brigitte
Bardot est-ce que vous donnez beaucoup
de ça beaucoup de gens qui passent ma
vie à m'occuper de ma maison
à essayer que ce soit le plus joli
possible
m'intéresser à tout ce qui intéresse les
femmes en général et qu'elle perdent un
petit à petit malheureusement mais vous
n'avez pas l'impression que vous êtes en
train justement de nous donner
l'explication de cette espèce de baisse
de l'agressivité vis-à-vis de vous
depuis quelques années parce que tout ce
que vous dites là depuis deux ou trois
minutes c'est extraordinairement
rassurant et vous offrez maintenant de
la femme une image qui fait qui fait
plaisir une image adoucissante alors
qu'il y a libéré je ne suis pas une
femme qui subit le joue de quelqu'un je
suis libérée donc on doit pouvoir
arriver à mener les deux de fronts à mon
avis on peut rester une femme et aussi
être libre et travailler mais il faut
pas que prenne le pied sur l'autre sens
ça c'est avez-vous le sentiment quand
vous parlez comme vous parlez en ce
moment d'être la même femme
qui se réfère au même notion qu'à
l'époque par exemple des dieux créés à
la femme enfin heureusement pour moi
j'ai changé et pour nous tous j'ai
évolué c'est le c'est le temps alors le
problème au fond le temps oui la vie
vous fait changer qu'on le veuille ou
non et c'est très bien je trouve
[Musique]